fifty-two seconds of spooky logos
Comcast smoothie really wants you to
focus on keys from here on out the title
the keyhole in the title the keys on the
gate and the fact that they're in five
keys New Mexico I mean god dammit movie
we get it also after 20 seconds of
keyhole imagery no one actually uses a
key in the keyhole also also why did the
series go away from the chapter titles
they used in the previous two sequels
this girl is drawing Slenderman wrong
why there's nothing to celebrate
Josh Stewart looks about as interested
to be in this movie as I do to be
watching it was wishing he was 32 years
old and he killed a lady with a hammer
he'd hurry by for his last meal she's
fun
Elyse thought I told you to put all
these toys away demons in with the
family by making random piles with the
kids toys because everyone remembers
poltergeist fondly cliche little boy
lived here a long time ago when he loves
playing with our toys I swear I believe
you sweet now she can blame anything on
ghosts how could you think about
anything else
these are more up living conditions than
district 9 the neverending race in the
spirit dimension was going strong back
in 1953 of course in the spirit to
mention it was closer to 2153 but we do
know that it was us that scorched the
sky ah oh that's her brother because
that's where the conjuring ghosts hang
out now this is one of those split
second jump scares that have you running
out of the theater yelling demons are
real to the frightened concession
workers but look at this guy he looks
like someone who got kicked out of the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles because he
didn't fit the color scheme you didn't
know the turtles were racist wow it was
1953 so you think the franchise creators
just have a checklist of what they have
and haven't done in this series meeting
a kid with a cane check
this and this it feels like loud noises
are the only thing this movie has going
for it brick Tamland would be proud
ghosts laughs for pretty much no reason
other than it was a sound effect that
the sound guy had in his cliche arsenal
of horror sounds vol 1 in the first 13
minutes there's been more key play than
the entirety of saw 3 which held the
record for the last 13 years it was a
good run while it lasted saw 3 so the
demon tricks Elise into opening the door
it fumbles around with the key for a bit
Elise his eyes go into the back of her
head mom comes down to check everything
out but is hanged with broken electrical
wire I'm not sure what the demon needs
with the key but mom's dead Lisa special
got it you know California that really
small state should be pretty easy to
figure out where she is from that
information tucker keeping the moment
alive in 2010 I wish I could help you
but I really can't I have to help this
man does every insidious movie start
with Elise saying she can't do the job
only to do the job within the next two
minutes this one I have to do hello
we're specks and Tucker just waiting
around the corner for Elise to throw her
suitcase in the car so they can make
this dramatic entrance movie blue it's
subtitle budget on cocaine and party
hats so they save money by filming
actual state signs oh man this hanging
ghost in the rear view mirror is in
terrible taste considering that's how at
least his mom died with respect City
it's starting to look like Leigh
Whannell had a clause in his contract
that if Angus Sampson was in a scene he
also had to be in it no matter how
ridiculous it looks nothing says take my
ghost hunting company seriously like a
logo that looks like it came from a
scooby-doo knockoff in the 70s
before we go inside I brought some
clothes for you boys you mean after you
told them that you were going to this
house alone and they showed up in this
truck and basically forced some cells
into this adventure you just walked back
into the house and got them some
different clothes before you left or
bought them on the way there why didn't
you just tell them that before or make
them bring different clothes some one
that belonged to Jack that's very
important to me well luckily both of
these guys are exactly the same size
also who watched the previous insidious
movies and decided they just had to know
where specks and Tucker got they're
indistinguishable and uninteresting
clothing juxtaposition jump-scare jumps
to position scare
did this guy rain a local church for all
their Bibles to build this Bible border
wall or did Elise's family-owned and
leave 116 Bibles at the house
foreshadowing the King James Version
camera so we can see what she sees from
a truck we call it the Winnebago s--
since they just purchased this truck one
would assume this setup is 100% new so
how have they had time to call it
anything even if a lot of the furniture
and items were left behind was the place
not clean before being shown to
potential buyers six years old woman who
knows for a fact ghosts and demons exist
really thinks that her brother lost the
whistle and even if he did lose it you
mean to tell me nobody looked under the
bed safe now yes no human dead or alive
can crack the security provided by
Elise's bra please even though Elise is
usually the one that sees the ghost she
conveniently can't see one when the
movies gone a whole three minutes
without a jump-scare
this ghost takes the whistle from Elise
which means pickpockets these days are
getting really sophisticated with their
techniques there's someone in the Andriy
girl who always gets in trouble when she
tells her dad that she sees ghosts
decides to tell him that she's seeing a
ghost again for pretty much no reason
other than the show how much of a dick
hole her dad was okay mark he just
looked so much like someone I know very
well she hasn't seen her brother in
50-plus years but somehow knows these
are his daughters come back here no you
weren't you're helping people but if she
were 42 minutes in and there's been
plenty of melodramatic and awkward
scenery but very little with the helping
and we do little of the insidious
Tucker's you have the still frames that
we printed yes I do
Tucker somehow knows this is the
specific photo Elise wants even though
she didn't ask for a specific one you'd
give this to your dad I think he will be
very surprised to see him and oh yeah
I'll neglect to mention that a demon
stole it two minutes later so my brother
who already hates me get his hopes up
then I'll bash them if he decides to
ever talk to me again when I was a child
I saw don't and you wanted it painted
black remember when I went into the
further defined Quinn Brenner
you know the last film where she
actually happened wraiths woman wets
whistle with wailing winds we still once
for yes twice for no are you the woman I
saw last night well damn you can use
that whistle surely you can just talk
right are you that entity what exactly
is the criteria for whether or not an
entity is lying does Elise have her own
whistle lie-detector test ready to go
whenever she goes to inspect the house
is what you want to show me behind this
wall this is the spirit dimensions
equivalent of using caps lock during a
tweet movie feels like it has to show us
every painstaking detail of every action
that takes place movie still cuts away
from Elise running to show specs coming
around with his glasses so why can't we
just get a couple quick cuts from her
saying keys and then showing back up
with a hmm which one of these generic
old-ass keys will go into the generic
old ASCII home um this one of course for
play look if the ghost made contact with
Elise and figured out the whistle
communication thing why did she just
leave the whistle on the ground and make
Elise play a point-and-click adventure
game what a dick I mean isn't that what
she's trying to do also to be fair ghost
girl probably just saved Elise from
getting whatever fucking disease you get
and totally deserved from blowing a
whistle you picked up off the floor that
hasn't been cleaned or swept in at least
50 years then why did she appear as a
ghost earlier does the rude Samaritan
ghost have some sort of projection
powers that show living people as
spirits in other parts of the house that
is a very specific power if you're
telling me that that was some completely
different ghost earlier then this movie
has way too many dead women who look
exactly alike haunting this place oh no
are you god damn dude if you're gonna
kidnap young girls and hide them away
wouldn't you have tried to stop this
long before your secret was out spec's
looks for a weapon rather than simply
running somewhere to call the police
this is exactly what insidious fans have
been waiting for a chase scene in the
dark not involving one ghost or demon
all right dude is incapacitated and man
that's like actual murder and stuff also
somehow I feel specs will get over
brutally murdering Ted quickly so we can
get on to some hot insidious the last
key action however this movie's pacing
is insufferable so the rest of the movie
could just be 40 minutes of specs and
therapy and I wouldn't be shocked also
also pretty sure this movie should have
just been titled Leigh Whannell as a
hero and awesome because he wrote this
seriously
we're a Leigh Whannell with two hot
girls threesome away from this just
being a vanity project disguised as a
horror movie but hey it's the fourth
movie in a franchise who's paying
attention at this point you stick around
for the next few days
be here I'm have to get statements from
all of you couldn't just get the
statements tonight
captain plot device seems to be on
insidious for time find it was some
silver whistle yeah about that at least
never told your daughter that the
whistle was missing again wouldn't the
photo lead you to believe that Lee still
had it also is Christian even aware that
the home owner died and isn't this an
active crime scene how did they even get
in the house
well Garza invite you up knowing the
risk that you might discover Maura
detective Whitfield must have used this
since video to help with his
investigation oh man he wanted to get
calm Kanako's just show up somewhere
other than behind another person for a
change how many ghosts and demons in
this series suddenly materialized that
someone's back shoulder who knew the
temple of gozer was located in our
deltoids don't mind me I'm just filling
in my calendar with all my events and
appearance is gonna be opening for
Beyonce on the 28th ah the old hide my
demon claw underneath a sheet on a table
so I can slap the out of someone with it
later routine classic oh no the demons
going after Elise's nice why didn't he
do something like this before when there
was a girl locked in a room down here
did he need Lisa's niece's Reese's
Pieces Lisa ceases Alicia Keys movie
takes an hour in two minutes two
insidious the last key punching a
keyhole in a human neck holy that scene
just gave me tinnitus how about you guys
you hear that dude guys I figured it out
the steamin isn't evil he's just trying
to unlock the mysteries of the human
heart but he's doing it too literally
someone needs to teach this guy about
metaphor stat what happened to her
there's something evil in that house and
now it has taken your sisters spirit and
I'm gonna find it and I'm gonna finish
it tonight
damn Elyse you're going to throw that on
a young girl about her sister and then
just walk away spectral sightings
doesn't believe in hugs I can see things
too I'm also an actress who wasn't
famous yet so I'm perfect to keep this
franchise going into the fifth chapter
and beyond come on boys let's get our
dancin in the house and get started
hmm how does this kind of thing work
Elyse was hired by the guy who kidnapped
a woman and locked her in the basement
and now he's dead and you just go into a
dead man's house where two crimes just
occurred and keep doing your work I need
things that were important to go herself
we spent one day with him but god damn
it if it didn't feel like I had known
him for years by the time specks
murdered him I feel like I know
everything that was in port
to him Bibles and kidnapping so let's
get as much of that as we can
chop-chop here is a Bible he held very
dear to him it was a Red King James
Version I know this Bible can be neatly
fell off the stack of Bibles earlier but
are you telling me there aren't at least
three or four other King James Bibles in
this stack that matched this description
well I get to death chamber he gets a
Bible Camp with beautiful girl honor
that's not guess you should have written
the script Tucker why are they looking
for this Bible here it was a whole stack
of them outside the locker room they
went into earlier and this isn't that
room any work gotta enjoy yourself go on
dates specs keeps it classy by hitting
on the girl whose sister almost died
earlier that dick
she wasn't dad insidious for seems to be
widely addressing a previously
unforeseen issue of ghost hunters not
being able to differentiate between a
ghost and a woman who has been kidnapped
tortured and needs house sure was nice
that the suitcase Elise needed was in
plain view from inside the room while
all the other suitcases were stashed
here where no one could ever see them
you weren't the only one Ana does she
think Ana doesn't know this or does she
think the audience doesn't demon waited
until Elise open three suitcases and the
movie gave us a false jump scare to
finally jump out of nowhere
what kind of sixth-sense bolt is this
and if they touch well the puddle of Ron
silver goo appear there is a special
place where the spirits come nice so
does that mean I'm dead or what I'm 11
so you need to explain this better you
have to go on doing what you do so could
she possibly change the past if she told
young Elise bitch you better stop
chasing ghosts with older release
disappear and be married to that guy who
used Domino's in the second movie how
did she know that since he didn't appear
until now and if you tell me it's
because she's psychic I will remind you
that the older and more experienced
version is psychic too and didn't know
he was there he's on the other side when
somebody has to go in and help her yeah
who's gonna do that I can't do they
would you like to do this if there was
ever a moment in the insidious franchise
that needed these two assholes fucking
around and comic relief in everywhere
it's when their boss is trapped in the
further and they need to hypnotize her
knees to go after her when I say now you
will open your eyes
and you will be maybe Tucker was just
being nice to let specks try to
hypnotize Imogen but with time being of
the essence and why didn't he just do it
in the first place not always shocked
when I see that the further has
television sets and that they can even
display static not the best cable
package in the world but still better
than Comcast on a handful of days in the
air
I hope you the further has tour guides
now that must be an interesting
interview process so the further daemons
grand plan was to put Ted so that he
would hopefully call Elise for help she
would discover he was torturing women
and then she would be able to cane her
dead zombie father this adds up is this
movie really saying that if Elise goes
on Return of the Jedi Luke Skywalker on
her spirit world dad that she'll go to
the darkside and be this monsters puppet
do I have that right imagine ex machina
it's a good thing Elise has seen the Saw
movies so she can have these random out
of context conversations come back to
her in the most convenient moment to
help her solve the further demon mystery
yeah I'm a demon let's slap people when
I'm angry you want to slap about it holy
this insidious movie is Return of the
Jedi
sorry so what does this guy go to extra
he'll now or the just a little further
wait why would she have the whistle the
last we heard her dad found it just
before her sister got attacked so he
just gave it to her after that that's
pretty convenient why don't you blow the
whistle demon picked the wrong time to
save her this finger key thing that he
does but main Lane what the does this
finger key thing actually do oh it's a
dead mom whistle also assuming this is
supposed to be the whole personal item
saves you in Khost movie this item was
personal to Christian so it should not
work for elites hands off my little girl
I mean is this seriously how they're
gonna win the ex machina whistle calls
in an ex Mach and a mother and the movie
just ex maka knows the count of the
demon that we never understood a movie
remember the first movie in this series
which was so much better yeah well whew
we're gonna make you keep watching this
one movie tries to retro actively
explains some bullshit from the first
movie I'm sorry not buying it in the
first movie after he fell off the ladder
we heard some noises and he looked
somewhere off screen but there aren't
any noises here if you're gonna explain
something like this at least replicate
what happened return to your body
go outstanding they were able to find
the hospital in the further with
absolutely no roadmap police way to make
your dad feel like for being mad at his
sister after he's been by your bed this
whole time terrified you were gonna die
helping people
why does at least need to keep helping
people when there's an obvious demon
slaying badass lurking around in the
further Elise's mom is the hero the
further needs even if she's not who it
deserves what the hell dude and by the
end of the movie Tucker says he gets the
girl I get the ticket so did specs
really get the girl was there really
romantic tension between those two this
is the most contrived romance in
sirmione and wrong oh hell yeah
this movie is setting up what will
likely be the best movie in the
franchise cannot wait until 2010 when it
comes out now dying through the keyhole
Scott you charge big you dive small then
you emerge big open this door there'll
be lots of light in smell the circus 20
there's peanuts cotton candy hot dogs
I came across a red door
[Music]
open this door there'll be lots of light
testing one two check check check one
check check similans supposed is that
you I know who you are she is lovely
isn't she
he's behind me isn't he
[Music]